bullet care podcast special guests in
here my guy Emilio Rojas what up man
welcome man so what first of all Emilio
how's it living downtown L.A we were
just talking you've been in L.A for a
while now I've been in La for a while I
was decided it was a good idea to move
to [ __ ] goddamn Skid Row bro I don't
live I don't live in a tent bro I'm not
like how has it been living in a tent
and using porta potties it was important
when the last time you shot in front of
someone's stew in the corner yo downtown
is crazy bro in L.A but this is La in
general man like coming from La in
general for sure yeah but downtown
is [ __ ] insane well because it's all
localized into like a small area yeah
like Skid Row is some crazy [ __ ] I've
been around the world I've never seen
anything like that yeah Skid Row is very
uh
you know it's always been crazy so it's
not like anything new but it's it's
definitely like like people choose to be
there I think well I think some people
choose to be there and I know like a lot
of people are just getting dropped off
like when the prisons get overwhelmed or
there's no mental health facilities they
just get dropped off that's where I
think when you get let out of County the
bus just that's what I think I I think I
heard that but I can't speak I think you
shouldn't think things
I think people are just getting dropped
off yeah no that's what I that's what I
was told oh I just never verified it
yeah uh shout out to Skid Row man yeah
I like watching uh just random
documentaries or like random Youtube
Vlogs about skid row because when I walk
over there man you walk over there no
not maybe not Instagram I don't think
kev's ever walked in school just
downtown in general I wear them ah it's
just everywhere what's uh where's all
the clubs at down there I've been
[ __ ] walking through crowd smoke yeah
oh for sure bro yeah Spring Street
walking through crack smoke 100 crack
smoke you see people shoot up like I saw
this guy
who was like dressed like a [ __ ]
legit like you know [ __ ] hypebeast
young white kid [ __ ] obviously had
money with Supreme doubt [ __ ] fire
ass like hard to find New Balances on
right
and I saw him walking and I was like uh
I was like walking past him when I was
going into a spot and I was walking back
the other way he was like huddled up
with all the crackheads and he like took
his little [ __ ] his little you know
his little man thing and he opens and he
pulls out the brillo and the crack and
he starts smoking crack with all the
homeless guys and I was like [ __ ] like
it must be funner like that can't be a
lonely drug like it must be funner to be
like yo I'm gonna go downtown we'll find
some people to smoke crack with because
it's better that way it's a social drug
for sure they're out there passing like
you want to be like the rich kid smoking
crack alone at home nah that's when you
really really lost you just want to be
the rich kid smoking crack with it with
all the home with all the other
crackheads yeah and just be like yo I'll
see you guys in two years I'll be right
here with you LA's crazy because it's
like you'll be in a place like skid row
and there'll be like a chick with like
fake titties homeless getting piped I
don't even know but it's like you know
she came here for something else she was
doing whatever and then just the city
just got her she got on that fetty WAP
yeah something fentanyl yeah something
bro that meth meth is Big out here
Fentanyl
he focused on Netflix
bro I heard that they're smoking
fentanyl now like they don't even want
they know what it is they're like no we
don't want uh we want fentanyl they're
used to smoking it now yeah they built
up the tolerance imagine building up a
tolerance this well that's what happens
with opioids right like you had opium
then morphine then heroin yeah you know
it's just oxes yeah it just gets
stronger and stronger and now they're
just like give me the fetty give me the
[ __ ] let's do it it's crazy another
wild downtown's wild have you tried
fentanyl
I've been I've been pretty pretty
fortunate to uh not have tried yeah just
make sure you're careful because you
walk through the wrong cloud of smoke
down there you might [ __ ] know oh
yeah I might have tried fentanyl on
accident a couple times that's terrible
by the way free fetty WAP
totally unrelated what happened he got
locked up he's in prison right now for
what
I don't know if it was fentanyl but he
got it was some drug [ __ ] he got he got
hit pretty hard I don't want to speak on
his case because I don't know the facts
but he's in uh he's in yeah he's locked
up he took a plea geez that sucks man